fuegos artificiales dieron inicio a la
ceremonia inaugural de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en medio de la
burbuja que busca contener el avance de
la pandemia en el icónico estadio nido
de pájaro se reunieron tres mil atletas
de 91 países de los cuales 10 son
latinoamericanos a la ceremonia
asistieron además unos 25 líderes
extranjeros las competencias comienzan
en medio del boicot diplomático liderado
por eeuu y al que se sumó canadá reino
unido de australia el rechazo a las
denuncias de violaciones de derechos
humanos en china
[Música]
el rechazo se evidenció también en las
calles de diferentes países este grupo
de la minoría musulmana uigur denuncia
desde el exilio los abusos a los que son
víctimas en china
persona esperamos que aquellos que
participan en los juegos olímpicos' que
respetan los derechos humanos y las
libertades levanten sus voces contra
esto
[Música]
porque es un crimen no sólo contra los
musulmanes y los uigures que viven allí
sino contra toda la humanidad
simpatizante de la organización
iniciativa del tibet que apoyan la
autodeterminación y protección de los
derechos en la región sentaron también
su voz de protesta
el espíritu olímpico y los valores
olímpicos ya no se respetan en absoluto
esa es también la razón por la que
estamos parados aquí protestando y
tratando de crear conciencia de que la
idea de separar los deportes y la
política en los juegos olímpicos no se
ha practicado durante mucho tiempo la
nación sigue el ipswich los olímpicos de
invierno en beijing no son los primeros
en sufrir un boicot
primero se produjo en 1956 en melbourne
en medio de la polémica el gobierno
chino espera que tras prender el
pebetero todas las críticas hacen